[Music]
hey everybody my name is Devon Wardell
I'm gonna play some music I'm gonna have
at least some info right okay this song
is called getting bigger it's on bunny
brawler I believe mm-hmm
which is under Evan Wardell music
instead of Evan more doubt because I
screwed up when I was licensing the
songs but this is what happens
he charged this my camera yeah just got
a light on it yeah I'm a professional
[Music]
see could be told that I'm not that old
yeah I know the way that I look there's
this feeling that I get comes from my
chest and it's hard to come away
undershirt it's getting bigger
[Music]
and I'm sick of being taught that I am
who I'm not you'd be shocked to know he
said it today
is there's this feeling that I get it
comes from my chest and I'm sick of
acting like it's okay it's getting
bigger
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're not gonna feel it
[Music]
we're not gonna we're not gonna
[Music]
we've been talking all night but getting
better and you're right sometimes just
feeling it it's good for the soul
there's still this gap in my heart and
the dressing it's the start but I'm the
only one who can make it
it's getting there
[Music]
we're not gonna
[Music]
yeah I did it did it Wow
so hard to actually be able to play two
instruments simultaneously and sing oh
yeah I hate it
hello everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don sake on very excited to be
talking about singing and songwriting we
have Evan
Wardell joining us on the show it's me
hello thanks for coming on oh yeah
thanks Alan very excited very excited
Evan Wardell and I were first introduced
at piano fight which is this awesome
indie theater here in downtown San
Francisco and that's also where Ron and
I met and Ron and Evan know each other
as well from working at piano fights so
it's really cool to be able to see you
you know in the state of being a
musician as well right yeah just doing
you know technical work and audio
engineering and that type of stuff light
work it's yeah I still subconsciously
warn my theater tech black so you're
supposed to wear when you're doing a
tech work and theater so no one can see
you it's like camouflage you wear black
clothes you disappear into the night and
for those that don't know Evan wore
Dells background everywhere Dells an SF
based musicians songwriter and audio
engineer his music blends vitriolic
passion with meandering psychedelia into
a soup of poppy hook Laden indie rock
that seeks to understand just what makes
its creator tick and you can find Evans
links below both to his band camp as
well as to his podcast we the listeners
calm and also his Spotify Instagram and
Twitter so Evan as we the listeners with
a Z with the Z that's right and that
link is below with me Helen you're
better than my publicist I don't have a
publicist not yet that's not yeah yeah
Ronson publicist Ronnie get him more
gigs come on what are you doing yeah
don't wait for me
so that's a little background on Evan
Evan I want to start things off by
asking we're gonna dive deeper into the
music and meaning
of it and why it makes you tick we're
gonna talk about that I want to start
things off with you're a current
analysis on the state of humanity
hoo-boy yes I like the I like the nice
easy just really easing into the
conversation hmm
we live Jesus analysis in the current
state of society of the world yeah Hume
and out there folks humanity against bad
out there did you just finish a gorgeous
guitar and harmonica and singing song
time yeah yeah yeah you try to make it
better in here because it's so bad out
there it's not that great in here all
the time but you know the music's fun
God I don't know we live in a time where
we have like unprecedented unprecedented
levels of like wealth and like
production of goods and you still look
around and see like pain and suffering
everywhere and it sucks in social media
is fun but also turns you into a crazy
person mmm and then it lets you indulge
in your most basic and probably
unhealthy instincts well write a song Oh
death and sorrow and greed and murder
you listen to the lyrics wrong that's
basically what it is most of my songs
are really about like god I don't want
to get up today I feel like going out
I'm so bummed out do they do have that
flavor yeah would you put like a nice
melody and thing around it and people
gets hopefully people get sucked into
the the nice way it sounds and then they
listen to and go oh god is this guy okay
would you say that the juxtapositions of
having so much globalized abundance
while simultaneously having the degree
of suffering that we have or the way
that we use social media to get good
messages out but also in terms of the
way that it disconnects humans from
actual visceral eye-to-eye experiences
this type of thing and trolling the
trolls and stuff would you say that
these juxtapositions are one of the
reasons why you have that
degree of melancholy in the music
probably yeah I mean you know it's hard
to track any individual feeling back to
some like larger like story or system
you know there's just like a degree to
which I can make that connection and
understand why it's a compelling story
but it's not like I actually know it is
true I've definitely gone on Facebook
and been like I feel so alienated and
terrible I'm like I'm not seeing my
friends I'm looking at this stupid thing
and it definitely does create you know
melancholy on the the lightest thing it
causes is melancholy if I only get
melancholy out of it that's like nice
usually it's like you know more
depression and like actual sadness and
does this have to do with the way that
you view both the way civilizations
currently existing and then your your
alternative potential world that we
could live in if we just organized
ourselves better so that again that does
the degree of sadness slash depression
come from the way that you see existing
civilization and you see the potential
that we could be organized better and
that gap is what causes the Welling
despair to be honest you know it was the
it was just the the feeling bad for a
long time and finding like some sort of
story to help explain all of that isn't
something that you know I really came to
until like I don't like three years ago
or whatever especially you know after
like the 2016 election it's like a real
real bummer for a lot of people but I
was definitely one of the people who's
like radicalized by the sort of leftist
analysis of the world that was offered
up by like Bernie Sanders
and then like the other people that I
sort of found out in the world
with the you know more concrete and
specific analysis that help sort of
explain
a thing that I had sort of just like
felt intuitively for a long time and I
think a lot of people just feel it feel
intuitively that like things are kind of
messed up and they're kind of like
depressed or anxious and they're not
really sure why so yeah I think like
with me specifically and I would even
like venture I would even like guess
most people they could they have the
feeling first I don't know why it is
they're just like I feel like [ __ ] today
and then they wake up the next day and
like I still feel like [ __ ] today then
you wake up I'll turn all their days and
you're like I feel ecstatic yeah yeah
ecstatic is rare but sometimes I wake up
and feel fine that's good yeah that's
what I'm always going for I'm just Ryung
to hit fine if I can get like okay
you know then that's good yeah yeah
we're on go ahead what do you what do
you drink on a regular basis I know we
got the wine going on right now yeah you
like whiskey or vodka whatever fine
bartenders that piano fight served me
shout out so so as we move trying to
inspire the kids you know they were
talking about trial but getting them
drunk yeah life is bad kids get drunk
get hammered a piano fight you'll
probably see me there
let's let's let's transition to the
journey side of things so alright the
journey the journey that's right yes
because I think this will give also a
deeper insight into the why the way you
feel the way you do at times
Ronnie turn those turn that phone on
silent
thank you feel like I feel like we got
way too hardened into depression real
quickly but yeah you brought up the
state of the world
ladies and gentlemen showrunner Ron
Vargas talking on the phone I was in
reference rating I was her portrayed
okay okay so born in Martha's Vineyard
over that East Coast was Evan Ward oh
and then that was me decided about 10
years ago to move to the Bay Area mm-hmm
and you were trying to get far
away from home yeah on an adventure with
your girlfriend it all started in the
Shire Oh tell us about this well I found
this magic ring yeah now you know I
think a lot of people grow up in a place
when they're a kid and want to like get
out of it you know yeah so I moved to
the other side of the country did you
pick up your artistic interests when you
were young like music yeah I've been
playing guitar since I was like I don't
know I want to say ten or so I remember
I remember the specific moment when I
wanted to play guitar it was that like
an end of the year like barbecue at the
middle school I went to and a friend of
mine got up and started playing they had
like a band and a friend of mine like
went up and played guitar on stage you
know but the some of the like some of
the parents were there and I was like
that is the coolest thing I've ever seen
I want to do that I must do that and so
I demanded you know I just wouldn't
bothered my parents forever and ever
till they buy me a guitar and yeah I
just went along from there yeah okay so
then started singing and songwriting and
playing guitar all this stuff yeah yeah
pretty much I think it was pretty clear
like as soon as cuz like music is I feel
like music is a great escape for a lot
of people that and it definitely was for
me and
I kind of felt intuitively that like I'd
have I wanted to like write things you
know I didn't just want to play the
songs that I know or that I'd liked in
fact like the idea of doing that was
like I'm just fun obviously but it I
could feel it just felt kind of like
cheap because it's like when you hear a
song you hear the full recorded song
like all the instruments and the drums
and the singing and the whatever and you
know as soon as you like play those
first couple cards and like smoke in the
water like bah bah bah bah that every
guitar teacher teaches you when you
start playing guitar you're like this
doesn't sound like the song I need to
record a bunch of guitars together and
you know all that so I immediately went
to like well I have to write something
because then I can sort of play it on my
own and I'll it'll sound the way I want
it to sound and then as soon as I did
that I was like this needs more
instruments on it and then I had a
little like like hand-me-down stereo
from my parents and it had two tape
decks on it and you could record on one
of the tape decks and then I realized
you could take that tape put it in the
second tape deck press play on that one
and then when you put another put a
blank tape tape and the other one to
ruin the first cassette tape deck to
record onto it'll record it over is
playing on the first tape okay so then I
realize you could overdub so you could I
could play like a couple chords record
on one tape put it into the next tape
slot put a fresh tape into the first
tape deck
press play hit record and then record
like a little solo over it or whatever
mm-hmm and that's how I discovered
multitrack recording recording that's
some that's really important yeah and
that that was really it was like really
liberating and still like blew my mind
and soon as you figure that out like you
know your brain goes to all the places
like how I can put drums on this I could
you know I could do this whole thing
myself yes
and so I've been you know doing that
ever since I guess yeah yeah Wow that I
loved that moment of inspiration for you
for realizing yeah track recording and
then like I do with tapes yeah - with
tapes - yeah
just digitally like we now have it was
funny because like each time because
then I just switched the tapes to get
the next go into it and the more time
it's recording to tape the quality just
degrades into grades grades so by the
time you get to the end of it it sounds
terrible but you're like it's all there
and it's like really exciting as a kid
and well and so what were the first
couple instruments that you decided as
your Ma's for your multitrack recording
as well as your singing as well yeah
well it's just yeah as like guitar and
yeah and singing this guitar first I
knew I wanted to like sing so I could
sing the songs that I write but it was
like a terrible singer forever
totally yeah still still marginal I'm
getting there
can you play the banjo banjo is a
terrible it's a terrible instruments but
if you could play the banjo you'd
probably play like Foggy Mountain
breakdown and then I might I would uh I
would know I would take it outside and I
would burn it it's like no the banjos
fine
the banjos are family has to play though
cuz it's like the strings are super high
up the frets the neck is like so this
neck is that's what it is it as it is
and banjo ducks like that thin yeah yeah
so just like weird to get your hand
around it and it's I just did
to hide this the string that's the
furthest on the top is the highest in
pitch which on a guitar it's the lowest
in pitch but then it goes to a low one
is next and then it gets like it's just
confusing to play what are we talking
about the banjo for you brought it up
all you know he knows Ron's like Ron's
the hidden hidden troll oh yeah no he's
out in the open well he relies on people
forgetting where didn't we hear about
the banjo from so okay so I love I love
the first dose into the into the
multitrack recordings that's that's
really important and then then what
about you know who you were when you're
in high school and then deciding you
wanted to get away from from
everything and go to the west coast um
cheese whoo I wasn't high school was
weird Oh a desperate weirdo we all to
some yeah like that's what high school
is you're like crazy and desperate I'm
like no no as I didn't like my parents
and I wanted to hang out with my friends
and I liked playing guitar and that was
like the three things that I knew but
yeah this is an interesting experience I
mean I I'm still super close to my
friends that I met in high school this
day so like it was a really like good
important part of my life like it seems
like an eternity but it was like and
even just like the last two years of
high school where there were the good
ones but I still just imagined that that
was all of high school for some reason
your parents got you a guitar so
shout-out to they did yeah
shoutout mom and dad ya got a guitar
that's that's important when each kid
wants to yeah explore into the music now
what about on the transition to the west
coast yeah that was so long ago I moved
here like 10 years ago in 2009 one of
the dumbest just blunders just no
thinking at all I'm like it was 2009 so
it's right after the huge economic crash
I remember and of course I was like 21
so I'm like wasn't thinking about
anything I'm just like I'll move there
I'll get a job whatever it'll be fine I
was like unemployed living off savings
forever I remember just like 20 people
trying to get the same barista job at
Starbucks it was like it was a nightmare
but I did bumble my way into a
rent-controlled apartment which I didn't
know was wearing controlled or even what
rent control was when I did now ten
years later I'm still living in that
same apartment and pay the same for like
a 500 square foot single bedroom
apartment as like many people I know pay
for a single bedroom so like it's funny
that I moved here at a time that was
such a terrible time to try to move
somewhere to find a job but conversely
rent was way cheaper
still like more expensive than most of
the country ended up being you're one of
your greatest treasures today is the
fact that you yeah through this big risk
and you moved out to the west coast and
a time when you were in your early 20s
to pursue something that was uncertain
for you but yeah you thought would reap
some good treasures yeah and you know I
benefited from a fair amount of
privilege so it was like kind of like I
I feel like I cheated a little bit like
I didn't have to scrape that hard
I like blew through all my savings but
you know eventually found a job then
what were you doing when you first moved
here booty out here you know hanging out
yeah trying to find work and failing a
lot yeah I worked for the 2010 census as
an enumerator
and walking around the Tenderloin
knocking on people's doors and be like
hey how many people live here yeah I'm
with the US government I'm with the US
government nope yeah it was weird
yeah but it paid really well it's good
thing about government jobs they pay
really good and I've got a really cool
side pack
side bag that I still have and it's been
like probably the thing that's sparked
the most conversation with strangers in
my entire life people are like what does
the you like they're like you have a US
Census Bureau bag it's got the big seal
on it yeah and it's just a really funny
like US Census Bureau yeah everyone's
everyone wants to know about the Census
Bureau bag that's great yeah they want
to know what questions you're asking
excuse me how many people live in this
building yeah yeah US government yeah we
so it's important you have to you
knowing how many people are actually
residing in the in the local cities and
in the country evident now what about
this this continuation of of the desire
for being an artist and a
singer-songwriter how did that continue
with you into the Bay Area and start its
own evolution here to be perfectly
honest I think it's just embedded itself
in me when I was a teenager yeah and
just attached itself to my like ego and
sense of self so I just have to do it or
I feel like I'm not doing something
right you
now it's it's weird cuz that's
definitely how some sort of like hobby
or artistic endeavor I feel like first
gets you in a way I mean like I've since
then found an amount of like not really
purpose but like meaning in writing
songs because before I was just trying
to like make something that sounds good
but now I've been doing it for long
enough that I can finally like write
stuff where I'm like trying to say
something even if that something is just
like inane or just like myopic or
whatever but yeah it's it's it's hard to
see how I know about like artistic
drives specifically just like I feel
like I have to do it and it kept like
every single week or two weeks or a
month or so you were at least performing
writing
I mean sometimes sometimes you go like
weeks without doing anything doing and
sometimes you go and you really want to
work on a song multiple days in a row
yeah type of stuff yeah I like to have
periods where I'm just like non-stop
doing it in periods where I just like
don't pick up a guitar for like two
weeks you know yeah yeah it's like hard
to find motivation and inspiration a lot
but you're on you're on your way now
you're I mean you're on Spotify now your
newest album little boys on Spotify now
and it's fantastic I like it a lot thank
you and this these are the types of
moves though that I think are awesome to
see artists and entrepreneurs doing
which is finding that spark within to go
and and build and create and especially
for all the young people that watch
around the world it's that finding that
spark within and just surrounding
yourself with other people that can help
you ignite your own spike you ignite
their sparks and yeah and building up
from there yeah yeah so okay let's let's
do an explanation of some of them the
meaning from the first song getting
bigger and also and also explain to us
again the complexity of the of you're
doing you you are yourself literally
walking multi-track yourself because
you're doing guitar harmonica singing
all at once and that's really really
interesting so teach us about the
complexity of that as well as the
meaning of getting bigger okay
complexity wise this instrument is
horrible it makes the fun sound
sometimes but it also as you're playing
with it
it you ask about complexity there's
gonna be me complaining about the
harmonica I like I've had a lot of out
of tune harmonicas in my life and that's
why I fall off playing it and then get
back into playing it because inevitably
it like goes out of tune there's like
probably a tiny little range in here
that's like good enough in tune that I
feel good about it
how do you
harmonica you you don't you buy a new
one you can tune them but the way that
you tune it is literally you get some
tiny files you go into these holes you
have to file depending but you can't
even see what you're filing so you have
to find the reed that you want to
there's two reeds in every hole there's
like this the suck Reed and the blow
Reed you have to go in and file it at a
different spot either at the base of the
tip depending on if that Reed is sharp
or flat you have to literally file it
yeah metal-on-metal yeah no one does
that people just buy new harmonicas yeah
they cost like 20 bucks no well that's
the thing the twenty dollar one suck I
like I like when I bought this one for
50 bucks and I did my research I like
looked at forums they're like okay this
is the best your honor it's uh what is
it
I think it's an Oscar Oscar whatever the
hell write the Oscar whatever the hell
is Oscar what have you oh no no free no
free plugs we'll invoice you yeah to be
honest I don't really know a whole lot
about harmonicas the only thing I the
only things I know about them are like
my experiences with them and they're a
pain in the ass and they don't like to
keep a tune and then also while you're
playing it like you've got a position
that just sew in your face if you're
playing guitar at the same time and I
know while I'm playing and singing I
like salivate a lot so my spit will get
into it and it'll the spit will
physically block the hole so I'll try to
like go to hit a note and it'll just go
and then like it'll push the spit out
and go yeah and like make a terrible
noise yeah but it's just that it's a
weird difficult instrument my friend my
friend and co-host of my podcast Bobby
good once described it as the the wet
and smelly mistress because it also he
smells like your breath because you've
like got your mouth on it yeah the whole
time and it's don't saliva
yeah that's boot germs that have built
up over time yeah interesting
okay now how about combining these these
the harmonica guitar and you're singing
all
until one note you know we we feature a
lot of neuroscientists and we talk about
the cognitive resources that you're
allocating to guitar verse harmonica
verse in yeah does it feel like you're
having a task switch between the three
nuts
so guitar I can pretty much deal an
autopilot on autopilot the the song I
just played is a little harder because
the the chord shapes aren't like normal
so I have to think a little bit more but
I can kind of ignore it for the most
part want some into it it's like and
you'll see if you you go back and
rewatchable find it and then the next
time I've just got it I don't have to
think about oh it's almost like I have
to re like get my brain onto the like
the the in grains and neural pathway
that's been created by me doing it over
and over again once I'm there I can I
can do it and it's the same with like
the beginning of lines like the first
note or two might not be quite on but
then I can like get it for the rest of
it so yeah I definitely have to devote
most of my what when I'm when I'm
basically the guitar is the easy one and
then I have to think more about singing
or harmonicas like like pretty hard for
me I'm not that great at it I don't have
to think about it a lot
and I only have you have to buy a
different key for each each harmonica it
has to be different keys is an F
harmonica so I can only play harmonica
on songs an F so I have to like capo
move this capo around and like change
the tuning to if I want to play
harmonica on a song and I have a lot of
songs like the song I just played is in
E so I had to capo it up a fret so then
I'm an F and then also some songs I
can't it's in a weird key for me to sing
so I I'm just like well I can't play
harmonica on this one because I can't be
bothered to buy another harmonica
but these are some interesting nuances
of being a musician is that when you
have a sequence in one of your songs and
you have this transition you know maybe
the guitar is more of a Auto piloted
algorithm and then when you have to add
your two harmonica and you kind of have
to you know discrete you know you're
rediscovering where that exactly is at
precisely and then you're like oh yeah
that's okay that's it yes it and also
like with the guitar there's like in
there's frets and I can kind of feel
them and there's also these dots here
interesting there's no place with your
mouth just like a computer keyboard with
the F and J you can feel this I kind of
know it's like about here about them yes
so I have to like blow a little bit and
luckily it's since the whole things in
the key of F I can kind of like blow and
like move my mouth up till I find the
right note and it'll still sound okay
because all these notes work in the key
of the song I'm playing it but it is a
weird and every time I just go like like
I'm paying attention to the guitar part
I'm playing and then go Oh cut I got to
start playing this for Monica part and
just like put my face on and blow and
it's the right note I'm like awesome you
feels like I totally lucked into the
right the right spot which is which is
fun and then how about some of the
meaning to the music of getting bigger
specifically and then we'll play up
Chuck after this well the music are the
lyrics the to the meaning of the lyrics
of yeah yeah it's pretty straightforward
so it's sort of over-the-top dramatic
but I like that style I like to sort of
like lean into the the weird drama of a
thing and give us some of the lyrics
yeah it's uh the the chorus part it the
verses are basically talking about these
are the first verses like sick of being
told that I'm not that all yeah I know
the way that I look which is just a
funny anecdote from life because I get a
lot I look way younger than I am if I
like shave if I get carded if I want to
buy tobacco so I don't do anymore mom I
remember when we first met then you
you were big on letting me know that you
know you weren't as you might have
thought I thought you were look a lot of
us have some pathologies okay I just
know what mine are but you still got
that all just trying to tell you no I
know it's just because you're ancient
and that guys that I've give you that
have been around the block for a while
yeah but anyway so that was just as I
don't know that was the whatever struck
my head at the moment when I wrote that
yeah and then but so giving taller on
with a little bit of a bear but there's
this feeling that I get it comes from my
chest I'm sick of acting like it's okay
so it's kind of like the sad thing I'm
like I'm I know I look like a young
fresh kid but sometimes I can be bummed
out too and all the verses kind of
follow this thing and then at the end
they referenced this hole or this gap
and then the chorus part is just and
it's getting bigger and then I guess
that's not the chorus that's more like a
pre-chorus I don't know it's hard to
just decide what's what and then the
actual Corsi part is we're not gonna
fill it today which is like sort of an
admonition directed at myself to be like
stop being such a bummer and stop being
so down on yourself sitting here and
like kvetching over it isn't gonna like
fix anything interesting and a lot of
the lyrics to my songs kind of follow
that pattern in one way or another yeah
where it's a lot of just sort of because
like when I write stuff a lot of time
just in a bad mood and it's like an
outlet for that some kind of like
singing about how I'm not feeling great
and then by the end of it I'm but the
end of like writing the thing when I'm
like in the sort of like writing flow
space it like feels really good and then
I like feel better again and so I want
to put like a happy sort of like or just
at least a positive forward thinking
sort of like coda to the whole thing
like I don't want every song you just be
about being bummed out unless I can get
to the end of it and be like you know
there's hope there's there's uh there's
there's there's reason to keep doing
whatever we're doing you know yeah yeah
that's this is another one of those you
you also kind of follow a like you just
described this path of of expressing
yourself through your lyrics and then
also reaching to your lyrics the way
that you want to motivate yourself at
the same time so it's kind of a little
bit of a roller coaster as well oh yeah
yeah oh yeah you have to have and that
just works on an artistic level you have
to like have some sort of journey in the
piece you know you want to like start
one place and end another place I like
to and as of I wrote that song probably
like
actually I think I wrote the original
bit like three four years ago and then
didn't finish it until maybe two or
three years ago and what was I saying
but by the time I got to the end of it
it was like I've completely lost my
train of thought no I say we were still
talking about the song getting bigger
but yeah you were talking about you
student at MIT MIT brought a lot of
hearts and then
okay let's transition an expensive
equipment yeah to the to the new album
little boy
we have upchuck downtown city slicker
blues oh yeah short for you short call
it up Chuck yeah yes every trade secret
every band every musician calls all of
their songs something other than what
they're called I I have to remember all
of my songs I call all of my songs today
I hate writing names for them but just
like I don't know it's annoying to me
because I feel like just calling it the
name of whatever's in the chorus is just
sort of like reductive and like dude you
think you didn't use any like it's not
an artistic process to name a song by
the thing that everyone's gonna remember
it by which now but then I've realized
just as a practical matter you should
just do that so confrontive yeah I did
that's right yeah it's an interesting
balance between the practicality of the
chorus and what you say a lot naming
that the song versus wanting to be like
different than everyone else yeah or
just like I want to feel like I'm not
just doing something in some sort of
like route on
intentional way you know I'm just like
this is what it should be so I'll do
that when in reality that's just what
you should do because you know it makes
it easier for people to find it you know
I don't really care what the song's
called that much but what I call all my
songs so I can remember them is the
first lyric of the first verse literally
the first thing I have to sing the song
is the thing I remember the song as so I
can just
you know it like puts me in the head
space to do it or whatever you know just
when I'm when I'm like putting together
a set and I see the words written I know
the first couple lyrics written I don't
have to think about what song it isn't
like oh it's the one that starts there
yeah
runs you ever thought before we entered
in song well I thought it was cool the
other night when I had asked Google to
play music from Evan Wardell and they
came up I want to know what it is that
that they decide what track it is that
they're gonna play
I will you aware that you could ask
Google to play music from you and that
they they can deliver me and Google
aren't on speaking terms
yeah that's I've only recently started
to ask Siri about things I got some hue
light bulbs at home I'm really psyched I
can walk into my home and be like Siri
make the lights red and then literally
cool I love it yeah
voice is a major part of the future some
people are calling it a even up to a
trillion dollar industry and just voice
algorithms it's going to be a massive
part of our future all right yeah it's
crazy let's jump into upchuck downtown
city slicker blue yes let's do it all
right
very excited transform this song
surprise surprise is about the city I
guess alright I want to get a good mix
here Ron wants to get a good mix hold on
everybody Ron's got to get a good mix
I'm gonna adjust this a little bit so
it's funny the two themes that I write
are like I'm bummed out and then the
other one is like walking down the
street you know
yeah like medical Mechanica is the song
that I tried to wrote right I love that
I love that we both love that song a lot
yeah and a lot of people really like
that one and that's literally me trying
to create an aesthetic that feels like
walking through the city at night like
walking home from like a bar whatever
and it's just sort of like hazy and like
trippy and
yeah I think I really succeeded with
what I was doing before there I remember
Ron actually was playing medical
Mechanica when he was sitting right
there and and I go who is that and he
goes that's Evan Wardell and I go what
and then that's when we were like let's
like look up Evans new Asylum let's have
him on the show yeah yeah yeah it's a
good song yeah yeah all my friends who
anytime anyone any time any of my
friends are like I liked that thing you
did it's always that song which is good
because I love that song too I'm glad I
have good friends with good taste
all right this one it's about the city I
guess I don't know it's not an F so I
can't play harmonica
[Music]
hustle it up us a little shop on the way
cross town gonna meet a woman trying to
keep on lunchmeat down it everybody
everywhere I want a piece of me now cuz
I'm living on the surface while I'm
working for the underground oh then the
ever any clamor rid of it and I tell
them how Oh
a freak
[Music]
something
[Music]
just
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so let's fill up with guts and hop on an
eastbound train just keep thinking about
the record while choking on my higher
brain hit everybody everywhere all gonna
feel the same as we all get together
talk about a ribbon to fame
hey I know it sounds crazy but it really
isn't all that say cuz I ready
don't be cheap knockoffs but on CG
[Music]
yeah cuz I should go
but I guess we'll find out
eventually they'll have to show us how
[Music]
the other stalling us they're trying to
suicide
nobody to lecture me and set me free you
found a million pounds of broken mouths
to town and can't you see you might as
well be just another [ __ ] just like
me just another [ __ ] just like
quiet down
[Music]
face to the crown let's do it now
let's do it now
please MacLeod
[Music]
great
yeah that's the song heaven hell yeah
thank you thank you thank you now
there's so many good questions along
with this one one one hi yeah I know
well we'll get to you know meaning gummy
water yes yes we got water for you
yes mean so this meaning of lyrics will
get there I want to ask you how you pick
where to have things like a solo happen
how yeah how do you pick you know how to
how do whinny when you go and you're you
know you're really strumming fast across
the strings versus when you're strumming
slower you know how do you how do you
pick your your your increases in energy
versus your honestly yeah you just have
to use your perfectly curated and
peccable taste I mean it literally is
just like I feel it
you know just like this feels like it
needs to do this now
I'll like be playing a song and then I
get to a certain point and I'm like and
I I just I just feel like I want it to
have this sort of energy change you know
and so I'd find the way to do that I
mean I'm all about the sort of like Evan
flow of the song I like it to get big
and small and then like groovy and then
I like it to hit all these notes and you
can feel it in this one yeah this one
has a lot going on in terms of like
energy changes including like playing
one part multiple times with different
amounts of energy because like the song
is really simple at its core note wise
this really just there's a verse in the
chorus and in a pre verse which is
basically the verse but louder and with
a little like melody over it and then
like the the bridge which is its own
separate thing at least in the way that
I think about it it's really simple but
you kind of like play with those volumes
going up and down and yeah it's that's
the one thing that it's not like a
really I don't know that I could
describe any sort of process I just like
kind of it's like a feeling it's like
it's like a painter in front of a easel
being like I don't know this needs read
you know it's yeah it's almost as though
the music is channeling through you and
you're feeling the how it's flowing
through you I want to ask how similar is
this to writing let's say we're writing
an article we're writing a story
whatever maybe we're trying to tell a
story let's say and that how does it
feel like when you sit down and you're
writing your music does it feel like you
can really get through a decent amount
of like an outline like a story arc of
what you want to tell them and you come
back later and fill it in a little bit
or teach us about what that's like I
usually begin at a like purely aesthetic
place writes find just a little a little
kernel of something I like be it a chord
change or a rhythm it's usually it's
usually a set of chords with a rhythm
with maybe a bit of melody over it or
even if there's not a specific melody
within the chords there's a sort of
implied melodic progression that I'd
like or I'm attracted to somehow and
then I just kind of build it from there
you know I'll be like I have this thing
I like and I'll go back and play it
every once in a while I've gotten in the
past couple years really into taking
notes on my phone and just like when I
have a thing that I really like I'll
break in my phone just record whatever
amount of it I have and then just forget
about it and then I'll come back to it
like maybe a month later when I've just
completely forgot it even existed and
you know see if it like still feels
inspiring and cool and like something I
should work on because for a long time I
would do this I'd write these kernels of
things and just forget them yeah I'd be
like oh I kind of like this I don't know
I guess I'll play with it later I have
some
lyric book that I read on my lyrics and
that I definitely have some lyrics in
there that I'm like I don't remember at
all what's supposed to go to this she
can keep these little bits of really
strong chord changes or or whatever it
may be and then you can kind of plug and
play potentially at later times if you
haven't embedded it yet into one of
yours pieces yeah that's cool I like
that's like you're building up a a
modular library of unique musical yeah
I'd say it's rare that two things I came
up with independent of each other like
get combined into something together
interesting it's usually each little
thing becomes its own song okay okay
I've definitely like written lyrics for
a song that ended up in another song but
it's pretty rare that they combined you
know it's more just like it's notebook
you know and you would build up ideas
you build a song around something that
you really liked yeah yeah that's cool
and then it's like I found this cool
thing and it really does it doesn't feel
like writing it feels like mining you
know I'm just like I went to the mines
today and came up with this gem I'll put
this over here and maybe go try to like
cut it into a shape and polish it later
you know yeah it does almost feel like
independent of my like almost doesn't
feel like I'm doing it you know it
doesn't feel like I'm sitting there and
writing a thing out it's just like I
bang my head against this piece of this
nugget until something comes out of it
that I like like I feel like like verses
will come out pretty almost like hole
formed for me you know I'll just like
hit on a sort of lyrical progression
that I like that almost writes itself
it's like you know I think in a way it's
sort of like you are mining you are
mining there's like neural pathways in
your brain that you did have that have
been primed to sort of
string together a piece of things a
bunch of things that you like in some
way and like you strike on one and it
goes like zip tip tip tip you get ahold
of bursts like all the sudden I'm like
oh where'd that come from but yeah this
is another interesting part of the
artists processes when you when you find
something like a really interesting
permutation of some music or some
writing or whatever your creative
endeavoring is if you kind of put it in
your library and store it for a bit
there's an opportunity cost because a
yes you may come back to it at a later
time with a fresh mind and be able to
add to it and then release it but also
it can just get stored in your library
and you can forget about it and not
actually bring it forth as a gem into
the world so there's kind of an
interesting opportunity cost with that
yeah I think it kind of depends the the
thing is like one way or another I'm
gonna write a little bit of a thing I'm
not gonna find its I've think of only
only like once in my life if I ever just
like sat down to write a song and
written the whole thing you know maybe
once that's ever happened I always come
up with a verse and then have to like or
like a verse and chorus and then have to
come back to it later it's yes and
silence usually helps a lot with these
things so you just sit if you sit and
you're not by your technology and you're
just more just just enjoying your
environment yeah I found it really like
to write in the morning like when I wake
up before my brains been polluted by the
world yeah they're you know interesting
something about just like making
breakfast and coffee and not being
plugged into like just the stuff the
matrix yeah a tricks is you kind of have
that time to sort of like brood or
whatever and it's you know I don't know
I just I guess I feel just like more
optimistic and like sensitive in the
morning I'm not beaten down by the world
yet there's still hope for the day
wasn't like super hungover although
written a ton of songs hungover - so do
you write when you're under the
influence I mean do you hang on to
did you know I save anything okay I'm I
suck when I'm like drunk I can't I can't
do anything thank you
creative endeavoring now with with with
with intoxication versus not with sober
it's interesting to the would
intoxicants also cannabis sometimes
psychedelics may be as well not just
alcohol so there's always room to play
and pick okay let's talk about the
meaning of upchuck downtown city slicker
god news that one lyrically is
definitely sort of gobbledygook nonsense
and is sort of just trying to create a
sort of like aesthetic it's like more
like almost impressionist like the
lyrics of the verse are a hustle and
bustle and a shuffle away across town
this is like trying to have have like a
hustle bustle II fun city vibe going to
meet a woman trying to keep all my lunch
meat down everybody everywhere want a
piece of me now I guess like those have
been trying to keep my lunch meat down
yeah yeah I remember when I was a kid
would call like like deli it sliced deli
meat lunch meat cuz you'd put it on yeah
one sandwich and I was just remembered
one day nervousness or anxiety oh yeah
it's like I'm there I'm trying not to
like throw subway or whatever and I just
liked trying to keep my lunch meat down
and just a funny like turn of turn
afraid not even turn afraid just a
couple of words together they kind of
make you go oh it's funny um good stuff
so yeah I guess this all makes sense
this let's gobbledygook than I thought
was everybody everywhere has won a piece
of me now got a million friends trying
to do things all the time so it's like
trying to like keep up with plans and
whatever and saying no saying yes things
that accelerate you potentially and yeah
you know I'm not trying to come up with
answers I'm just trying to like create a
embody of like a feeling or environment
kind of like like I feel like a it's
rare that you know a painting tells you
what to do or is like prescriptive and
what it's saying about how to be or
whatever you know it's sort of like it
presents you with a an image and it's
trying to like create or like represent
some sort of feeling or some yeah it's
trying to create some sort of feeling
generally I feel like so yeah that's
that's usually what I'm trying to do I
kind of I'm into the like I come from it
from a very aesthetic place and having
like a literal meeting is something that
sort of emerges afterwards maybe but
it's not always like a thing I mean or
like a thing that's real you know even
when I'm saying like I or me I might not
be even might not even be talking about
a thing that's about me although
recently I've done that a lot more I got
really into like bright eyes probably
like three or four like four years ago
bright eyes bright eyes or five years
ago meet what is it it's a band okay
Connor Roberts great recommend him check
it out okay and he writes like really
good like the very personal at least
seeming songs I don't know about I don't
know how much of these are like actually
him talking about experiences he's had
or whatever but and I just got really
into that so it took me a long time to
actually like express by self and like
what I'm feeling and I've sort of like
gotten into that more in the past like
probably five years yeah yeah that's
which is good fun yeah yeah it also is
most its most relatable to your life
journey and then you get to express that
through music it's the most cathartic
for me to write articles right yeah
yes yes okay I want you to you know here
we have instruments and we have you
singing and this is not being played
through you know live in person is not
being played through a a compression an
audio compression digital audio
compression and we were streaming this
yes getting people so this is the key
right so that's what I want to ask you
about yeah so Evan how many years you
did audio engineering here at San
Francisco State University I did there
recording industry program recording
industry program so yeah and that was
almost how many years ago is that e
something like that
so my here's a here's interesting thing
is when you understand audio engineering
like Evans coming in here and he's like
yo there's all this stuff with the mixer
and the mics and everything and and so
that's had the mics pointed the wrong
way I know I know
newbies were newbies we're trying to
figure things out I do remember watching
this before watching an episode of being
of there's something like that Mike I'm
pretty sure that's not supposed to go
that way this is the first episode we're
doing with with the audio technica mics
we were laughs but then we did maybe we
use some of these you know why are you
watching our [ __ ] not liking it or
making comments why don't you comment
about the mic you know you're not
supposed to use those mics like that
watch get you help out people you know I
don't get on the defensive when I get
corrected Ron that knowledge isn't free
you had me on the show so I'll help you
out yeah me turning this 90 degrees it's
pro bono you don't worry about it so so
then with this audio engineering
knowledge a couple questions are you
know because of the really interesting
you know you were giving this example of
having a multitrack player that would
then make you know multi single track
that you could record on top of again
making a multitrack this type of stuff
and seeing the evolution of the
technology and all the way until now
where we have the equipment that we have
so I want you to talk about the
importance of the technological advances
we've had in terms of what it's done for
music industry but also how crazy it is
having a guitar right here in person and
the by
bration that you get from that in the
quality you get from that versus when it
gets compressed through the digital
compression algorithms and out through
piece of speakers have been hit us it's
all about that knowledge wait so was the
importance of music technology the
advancement of museums mythology oh yeah
and that I could do yep let's do that
and then after the other one I can
figure it got better so life is better
for everybody I don't have to do crappy
recording on a tape recorded over and
over and over again into oblivion
because that has its own type of
compression compression is a really good
thing I have to say by the way I feel
people like I think people have this
intuitive sense that you want the raw
[ __ ] you want it raw and uncompressed
but like compression is really helpful
and it and enables a lot of different
things and also you can be careful by
the way that we're using the term
compression because compression there's
like the digital compression that you do
to a file to make it smaller to send it
like over the Internet and then have it
uncompressed which is not my expertise I
don't really know a lot about that or
the compression that turns a raw audio
file into a mp3 as opposed to a lossless
audio file yeah again I don't know a lot
about how they do that or how that works
but there's a a quantifiable difference
in the caliber yeah yeah yeah when I
export an mp3 from my recording program
and listen to it next to the lossless
wav file that I export it's like years
difference Wow I look like I listen to
the mp3 and I'm like did I do this wrong
like no but then I like [ __ ] up somehow
cuz it like sounds so bad but I don't
know yeah then that doesn't thing I
don't know how to mess with like
compression settings to make those sound
good but back to the advancement of
audio technology it's really great
remember when I first so I went from
like recording on it because
that tapes to getting a little digital
recorder that was like this big and
could record like eight tracks yeah
and that was like really fun to use and
da double use recording software was
really expensive and sort of prohibitive
at the time but now it's gotten really I
mean relatively cheap I guess I still
have to spend a bunch of money to I got
I got a student discount on Pro Tools I
only that's Pro Tools is we could have
used you at that Afghani gig we did the
other night with Pro Tools is great no
we just need when we when we record a
live performance with multi tracks
it's really hit or miss I we've had this
conversation before to get that to get
that mix you need you need your multi
tracks you need your vocals your guitar
you base your drums all on different
tracks to remix it if you can do it on
the fly you know that that's great yeah
you know you should be making a lot of
money but with what you need Pro Tools
or no and yeah and and there's not I
remember like Pro Tools was the injured
industry standard when I started getting
into recording on the computers more
mm-hmm
now there's like a million of them and
they're all great you know you can get a
cheaper are they cheaper not really
I'm still pretty expensive well nowadays
everything you can't just buy the
program anymore like I have sort of like
license that's grandfathered in so I can
read download it when I get a new
computer whatever but if you're like new
to the the Pro Tools world you have to
basically do the renting system or like
a subscription yeah don't the
subscription in the Adobe Club yeah
premier Photoshop yeah everything's
right but that is that that does make it
easier as like an entering initially
it's a lot of money over the long term
but you can you know if you want opt in
opt out yeah often opt out and having
access to even just the basic plug-in
suite and in a program like Pro Tools is
like I've liked all these songs they
just did with the basic stuff and Pro
Tools cuz I was very poor for a long
time like it's far like nicer really
nice equipment
are nicer plugins or whatever so that
advancements been like great like you
know you can do a professional recording
and your with rules on your yeah you can
do with GarageBand you know GarageBand -
yes - is a huge pain in the ass to use
but if it comes free with your computer
the tools yeah that's very interesting
so the tools have been democratized to
the point where we can express more of
our artists to know that I would say
democratize well GarageBand causes your
computer like you just said and so yeah
we don't vote on that well don't say
well the democratization of a tool also
means just the wide spreading of it in
terms of depositing the pricing of it
the wide spreading of it so sure now
comes with the the the computers that we
purchased then it makes it easier for
people to express themselves
artistically yeah because now they don't
have to have these bulky ass big ass
equipments and you can get audacity on
the internet for free yeah and the
companies actually spent all the
equipment that's behind Iran right now
and all the equipment that we have now
on this set basically 20 years later
plus the years later plus then what's
happening after this in the next 20
years whatever the technology will be
it's these companies and the engineers
and designers that work at these
companies that push the boundaries of
what existed you know a couple decades
ago with Iran's equipment to the couple
to the current systems and then to what
the future systems will be so it's good
that we have these incentive systems for
companies to push the boundaries of what
exists to make it easier for us to have
democratized tools for artistic
expression of all sorts okay
yeah so then your the last point that
that we we cover you actually covered
the compression as well you're like okay
so okay there's also yes a compressor
which is an audio tool that's very
helpful and helps you fit things
together I'm learning that myself i dag
that would come in yeah they can
actually like in a way add fidelity like
people think of compression and the
digital senses removing fidelity you can
add fidelity with a compressor yeah in a
sense you remove your exchanging in a
dynamic range for fidelity which I'm
just glad I got to say that sentence but
basically what it does
it's a it's an automated volume knob you
set a threshold level and when the audio
goes above that threshold it turns the
volume down by a certain amount trysting
oh that sounds that'd be great for all
the peaks that we have and yeah go haha
laughs or you know go yeah yeah yeah
every time I've worked with you guys I'm
like we gotta get some compressors in
here but they're a really useful
audio tool which adds fidelity in the
way that it makes the quieter parts
louder really what it does is bring the
larger part the louder parts down and it
brings so then you can require louder
well then you can turn the whole thing
up oh so that's how you use a compressor
to make the quiet parts laughs yeah and
yeah so that's tools like that at all oh
yeah they're great there's a million
ways to but yeah that's a compressor in
the audio basically an if-then statement
if the decibels reach above seven yep DB
and then just bring up the bring down
what goes above that seven yeah you line
back down to yes yeah and then you can
consider ratio so you can like have it
reduced by half by a third oh that's
great yeah these are these are rock you
can choose how quickly it catches the
signal so you can have the peak of the
loudness come in and like get that
loudness for a second and have a clamp
down afterwards
so that that retains some of the
transients that makes it sound less
compressed it just kind of retains some
of the dynamic range so it sounds more
like full of life or whatever yeah
because that's that's the one thing if
you compress stuff too much it just
starts to sound like dead and like you
know the this with the songs I write I
like the energy to go up and down and
you want to retain that this sort of
like changes in energy and you can
definitely overdo it with tools like
compressors so yeah it's yeah it's the
whole thing your whole thing kids yeah
audio engineering I'm glad that you're
bringing up all this nuance to it
because the more that we can understand
how it actually works it's like
double-clicking into audio engineering
and like looking deeper into it versus
just seeing it at the surface level
whatever you're like at a restaurant and
you order food and you've never actually
worked in the kitchen we're in the
operations of a restaurant it's very
similar you got a double
click into the restaurant to be able to
know what it's like getting behind the
eyes versus same thing of the audio
engineering just be nice to your servers
that said don't be a pain in the end
thanks to the audio engineers yeah nice
to me too man I got to tell you doing
like sound for live events I've never I
don't think there's an another job in
the world where you get more unsolicited
opinions about how you should be doing
your job then when you're like the sound
guy at an event it's interesting it's
always and the musicians are always cool
it's like the mom of the lead singer oh
yeah that we had in San Leandro was that
we were dealing with that sort of stuff
yeah it's a tough world out there yeah
you know there's difficult acoustic
environments all over the place when I
work at piano fight it's just like good
sort of difficult environment to work in
I can't turn things up too much or get a
lot of feedback and it just it's a whole
thing yeah but there has been
improvement to that that system out
front and anyway are you talking about
out front yeah yeah they definitely went
through there's a significant
improvement a little bit give him at my
behest good keep on took a lot of I'm
just constantly poking coal being like I
need this I want this cold eyes alright
it is fine you do a great call you do a
great cold shout out to piano fire yes
big war my piano picture yeah okay now
on the way out we want to ask you about
the two things that you were teaching us
about your band the green door five
doors five years and you guys play
they've been around for like eight I
joined them like maybe five we've got
five piece five piece band five piece
band two guitars drums keyboard and bass
yeah bass and then and then you guys
play about monthly or so around the bear
yeah okay
and then also so what are your shows
yeah may 16th at the Parkside oh maybe
16th at the Parkside okay I think it's
the six what times if the full five
piece band is playing there it's at show
time I don't know seven yeah no just
four of us our keyboardist lives in
Sacramento and he's
he's a teacher um so he doesn't know his
can't always make it no no teachers
about the complexities of being a part
of a five-piece band this is again it's
hard to rally the uh you ever tried to
get five adults in a room together very
hard not at work really hard to get
people together yeah you know those
complexities are the complexities of any
sort of relationships you have with
groups of people an individual who's
deciding on on the songs on the lyrics
on the on the when the instruments come
in or when they go out you know we
generally it's like a mix of sort of
like a tour ship where one person takes
control and collaboration you know
generally someone will bring in a song
and then we'll all kind of play it
together and we'll either like jam on it
to figure out what we want to do with it
or the person will have a very definite
idea of what they want to do and then
you know because we always want to like
serve the artistic direction or impulses
of like the person who wrote it so you
kind of like that person will have like
as much or as little control as they
want over like how it goes and you know
it's like so we'll either like let
someone direct how it's how the song is
gonna come together or we'll just
suggest parts or you know there's like a
myriad of different ways
something can kind of come together it's
a sort of ongoing evolving process that
it's not always clearly defined yeah so
sometimes it's in individuals taking a
little bit more authorship sometimes
it's more of the collective authorship
yeah you guys have to practice in order
to be able to determine what that is for
every song and yeah and it's like it's a
it's a relationship that we sort of like
navigate
all the time kind of like figure out the
best way to do it yes yeah it's a it's
interesting it's a fun time yeah you
love those guys we have so much fun
together the these are the again these
are the the questions of how humans
build things together it's similar with
a band as it is with you know Ron and I
building simulation or any startup
that's working together with multiple
founders this is all this is all very
even a couple in like a relationship how
a couple two people end up starting
family all this different type of
dynamics so it's interesting to be able
to think about in terms of a band and
how that works with leadership yeah we I
think the one sort of band specific
thing or this is like true of art
generally like when you're creating art
with a group of people because it's kind
of it's the rare complication of like
it's your leisure thing like it's the
thing that you want to do for fun so you
like when I have a good time but it you
also want to do the work to make a thing
that's really good
so there's like a lot of different sort
of competing impulses or now what's the
word like like balancing out the
pinnacle of artistic expression with the
desire for leisure kind of what's the
word I'm thinking of I forgot a word
dichotomy no no but there's like
competing incentives not just between
people but like whole entry competing US
incentives yeah not just like between
people but but like between in your own
brain you know like you want to have a
good time you want to like get stuff
done yeah you want to like you know like
band practice like we want to hang out
in chat but we also want to like work on
music so it's like it's definitely an
interesting sort of relationship to
navigate nutri sort of like do you take
charge are you the guy you the leader of
the band
oh no by no means really I would think
you would be no no no no it's I mean
there's no like leader really someone's
gotta take charge the thing is like
generally whoever wrote the song that
we're writing leads that process and
then when it's like you know like the
people the guy people always want to
talk to his mic cuz he sings most of the
song so he's kind of like the face
although the like secret face of the
band is our drummer cuz she's she's got
the the most like definite sort of like
artistic vision oh that's great
her name Vanessa Vanessa so some very
cool and good people awesome
but yeah it's that's also interesting
dynamic is the the singer is the face
sometimes and then the drummer can
sometimes have the big vision or
whatever and there's these so yeah
competing incentives and stuff and yeah
yeah yeah then and then our basis is the
head of Transportation he's got the big
track yeah I'm the head of making jokes
onstage you know we all have the part
that we play okay that's the green door
and you said May 6 makes 16th I think
May 16th yeah I'll pick up that right
okay all right I'm not gonna pick up my
phone yeah and then so the you you can
find the green door the performances and
locally in the Bay Area as well some of
the music online as well yep okay
Spotify Spotify all that stuff okay now
we the listeners is your podcast that
you had cast yeah yes this is a once a
week podcast where you speak on music
production music news to music in
general yeah and this is this is cool
because then again it's one of those
things where you're you're you're
building up your knowledge base on the
subject of music by doing a podcast that
than other people listen to you're like
you know this is a good wait I think
other people listen to it I'm not sure
yet
only one always start with zero
listeners they yeah yeah those four are
just me listening to it four times
how are the we the listener
was that it's really fun I'd do it with
a really good friend of mine from high
school who we like sort of lost contact
for a few years and then recently got
back in touch like a year ago and it's I
mean in a lot of ways the podcast is
just the way for us to reconnect and
like talk to each other but you know we
like to talk about the music stuff we're
doing you know we're both interested and
he's also a writer he like writes and
sings and he's like getting more into
audio engineering now and so we just
kind of talked about all things sort of
music related and just make jokes and
have a good time and it's it's fun I
enjoy it we the listeners with a Z with
a Z www in there cuz Bobby hasn't
figured out URL stuff you know the
Internet's a tough place so and you can
find that link in the bio to to we the
listeners okay we want to ask you a
couple questions on the way out what
questions we ask on show and then we'll
all the questions and then we will wrap
with a song from one of your upcoming
albums which we're excited to hear we
have not heard that one yet alright
first simulation question okay just do
are we alone in the cosmos
probably not I don't think they're
coming here but they're probably out
there I think people who think the earth
has been visited by aliens are crazy
it's just there's no way do you know how
much energy it takes to get anywhere
it's just crazy
yeah but they're probably out there I
mean in the sense we are alone because
we're never gonna see those people like
ever like us as a species we'll die out
before we ever make contact with anybody
well well we'll die out before the
messages that we've sent through like
radio broadcast to different galaxies
that gets anywhere you know we're like I
like material like what's the word
practically were alone but like
literally probably not and then
I want to ask Kevin about what exists
beyond the 3d reality are you very
spiritual do you think we come in to
earth to play in the earth suits beyond
the 3d reality is the fourth dimension
time yeah and then everything beyond
that is a fun thought experiment people
do on their stone I remember someone
wants showing me a video explaining the
ninth dimension I'm like yes this is an
interesting thought experiment but it's
like can't what nice yeah I I could
really take grasp the fifth yeah a long
night so I said what's the fifth
dimension it's beyond life death it's
like a show that's what you have to get
in touch with your darker side of life
and death death to the fifth dimension
is beyond death so an idea an pre-birth
pre-birth fifth dimension is also pre
birthday yeah I just tried it yeah I'm
doing the best I can all you can do is
imagine what it might be or mean but
there's no way like if these things even
exist 3d all we have is 3d understanding
everyday maybe I've been waking up as
Ron Vargas for 52 years go on
that's my 3d reality that's all I have
and so yeah maybe to poke with the
scientific probe at what exists past the
3d which hopefully we can like we can
get there yeah there's the fourth D it's
time okay
let's ask the next question okay okay
are we in a simulation no no again a fun
thought experiment people like to do the
stupidest make any sense I mean like
made like it's so they came out with
that that that study that said like or
there's some scientific experiment that
said we got a result that suggests that
it could be possible that we're in a
simulation which is like which is like
you take a piece of paper and let make a
shadow on your on your hand and you're
like well that could be that could be a
different planet I mean like we did I
don't know maybe it's it seems again it
seems like a dumb thing with people that
people with too much time on their hands
waste their time thinking about because
when they confront the actual world in
the actual problems they feel helpless
and atomized and so they retreat into
these weird ideas about like fifth
dimensions and the world is a simulation
but sometimes people do execute quite
well in the 3d as well as contemplate
some of the past 3d philosophies as well
so that's just think the thing to put
out there I guess I guess I've been last
question on the show okay what is the
most beautiful thing in the world that
like moment right when you wake up and I
realize you don't have to go to work and
just like go back to sleep let's see
it's the best
it makes me weep with with with joy at
the the beauty of existence when I can
go back to sleep that's yeah
that's first time we've heard that
answer on the show that's the only thing
that they're just pure your joy that are
like I don't know like heroin or
something I mean I you know doing heroin
are you with me I just want to say that
to anybody that's watching risky
business kids and there's a big problem
with addiction to opiates not just just
the poppy and opium
no just opium them I'm not a big fan of
opiates and I'm glad about that
someone's finally saying the things the
people want to hear and heroin is bad
we're in public service announcement
though it is just very very very careful
yeah actualizing the fullest potential
into the world yeah yeah but but but
back to the beauty question yeah I think
like things that are beautiful or the
concept of beauty can be like really
fraught and there's very few things that
just
I don't know are like purely good and
joyful and I feel like the really hard
and like you know separate like removed
from all the things that make you feel
bad I don't even know if this is like a
good if if that makes it more beautiful
if it's separate from the things that
make you feel bad but it's like the way
you were describing it was that when
you're waking up and you're realizing
like oh there's no burden on me to have
to actually get up and go and so I can
actually sleep these extra couple hours
which in many ways people desperately
need those a couple hours I was thinking
specifically of the like when when you
like go to go back to nap a little bit
or whatever you like stretch a little
bit and then just that feeling of like
pure relaxation runs through your body
that's that's the best that's good stuff
that's that's the most beautiful first
time we heard though yeah I like that a
lot this has been such a good show I
really appreciate you coming on and
teaching us about you know your life
your journey I'm a teacher now singing
songwriting yeah yeah your newest album
everyone go and check out all of the
links below we have Evan Waddell VanCamp
calm yeah we are tuning oh yeah you too
yeah we're closing we're gonna be
closing out with a song from one of
Evans upcoming albums he's gonna be
tuning right now everyone go and check
out the links below to Evan Wardell
VanCamp comm also we the listeners
dot-com is the podcast you can find
Evans newest album little boy it was
released in January 2019 we highly
recommend checking out medical Mechanica
it's one of our favorite songs he played
upchuck downtown city slicker blues from
that album as well so go and check that
out and Spotify the links below his
Instagram and Twitter link as well as
below and much love thank you everyone
for tuning and we greatly appreciate it
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below on the episode go and
share more content around singing
songwriting and becoming an artist
around your communities huge shout out
to Ron Vargas our producer and director
we love you very much thank you Ron
and also support the artisan
entrepreneurs that you believe in in
your communities support simulation our
links are below as well we would love
your support helping us scale much love
thank you so much for tuning in everyone
and we are going to be out rowing with
Evan Ward Elle's song from one of his
upcoming albums thanks everyone much
love peace yeah I would have loved to
play medical Mechanica
but that's one of the doesn't work
without a band it doesn't translate 12
acoustic so it's funny when I play
because all the stuff I ride record is
like me doing it solo I have to be
judicious about the songs that I play
cuz not all of them work that a bunch of
stuff but sometimes I can make them work
with it this thing and this thing okay
you know stop [ __ ] the song doesn't
have a name but it's fun
[Music]
I think only ever really cared enough to
get by like old man sitting in his chair
just waiting to die while the postman
waits to get out of a bust
you know it's hustles downtown to
deliver to the rest of us and it's hard
to be kind but it doesn't really see the
mind but I'm still gonna give it a try
I'm just lucky
[Music]
cousin empathy starved in a morally thin
I don't think I have the strength
through the courage to get up again
there's this mountain of guilt at the
center of town even busy folks take the
long way get around
and it's hard to ignore but you can do
it if you know what you living for I'm
not sure
[Music]
I feel like I'm outside if it
[Music]
the show's gotten out and everyone's
left I'm still here at the bar why live
in a home
[Music]
I'm so sick of singing
I just wanna shower yeah my mind is a
gutter clean it out you can sit here
forever in this horrible place get the
[ __ ] up go out face the day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whoo it's a song thank you yeah that was
great
hey guys yeah thanks bye-bye
you turn off the stream now somebody
goodbye it makes sense okay yeah good
yeah those fun did it oh thank you
[Music]